my name is Greg
his name's Kyle I lament the Cuyler Minh
on Twitter and Instagram wine and wild
on periscope and has a channel the words
called fan theory yeah we go for that
hey Kyle yeah what's my ethnicity
that's brick you can you are part I'm
actually half Filipino yeah I knew it
wasn't fear and f4 something like that
so so I'm in your part Philharmonic as
the Filipino subscriber base has been
increasing they've been asking me to
watch these commercials and I'm a I'm an
obvious not as here that right yeah
you're not see and a Filipinos I guess
today this was called daddy's lies or my
father is a liar I've had countless
requests for this the first person to
request this shark-tooth oh five oh I
think he's got that one at BP of here
try yellow and big disgust and he gotta
be ashamed of yourself here 2005 let's
watch this cause we are we both you know
had easygoing relationships our dad was
do this
daddy is too sweet the study in the
world daddy is the most handsome - my
god
[Music]
funny he is my Superman 31 sweetie usual
at school daddy is just great
but he loves what are they doing this
precious moment he lies
not having a job he lie about having
much ha ha ha ha kela that he is not
tired
[Music]
he loves that he's not hungry
he lies that we have everything
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
haha
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jeez that's heavy
you damn Filipino brothers and sisters
God I can't say a massive commercial
today I was like you know what is what
I'm not gonna cry [ __ ] that was
heartbreaking
ah ok I couldn't even speak I was just
like that's God I don't
welcome to Filipino commercial oh my god
oh my god I'm just that was really
[ __ ] oh my god she's so cute there's
just they're so evil they're just like
oh look happy ha ha
what I was just glad I did good on the
direction of like he's a liar he's
really a bad guy for doing that designed
to protect his daughter and but his
daughters like well aware that he's like
sacrificing a lot my god when he finds
out in the letter he's reading and then
he's like he he of course doesn't want
her to know like man and then he finds
out that she knows and then they're both
like crying my god that was just oh that
was so hard
Bravo whoever produced it really is
touching my god what a great ass
deported I think like life insurance
[Laughter]
course I remember
she's armed my dick isn't starting off
I'm ready like getting like a little
misty eyes I'm like I don't get Hamelin
I gotta handle this I'm like I don't
have to cry right now because I don't
have like every most of these
commercials I'm like tearing up anything
with karyn's gets to me anything with
parents gets to me you know I like my
cuz I grew up poor and my family always
struggled they weren't exactly like like
him were they really ideot from your
from us you do know the hard work and
sacrifice your putting and just keep you
afloat and keep keep things moving and
keep things alive that is going in like
you know a child's intuition is a lot
stronger than I think a lot of public in
real life is they're not stupid kids are
not dumb and I know that from being a
kid enjoying other kids when I was a kid
and they have and I get older you think
it don't know much but they always know
I love the spin on it of how you know
she's calling him a wire you think it's
gonna be like this is she's let's call
them out on some [ __ ] right now but
Yeley she's I was prepared for him to be
like an international super spider looks
like a favor I didn't ladies a hitman to
happen daddy has a family outside of it
yeah especially on the thought of what
lying is you know because sometimes
people say it's better to lie about sort
of things if it's to protect someone and
not harm someone I love that the little
girl in this commercial really
appreciated what her what her dad was
doing like same pretty much laid on me
yeah guys because like I was going done
yeah because of me like I was like the
oh [ __ ] is so sad I want that little
girl I want to just hug her and take her
to Disneyland this is the kind of father
I fear like what mad respected like the
dad like that
parents like that who like are going
through hell and turmoil but they do
their best he's a good dad is it good
dad yeah really good dad because a lot
of times we look at like parents like
what equals a good parent that can
provide and he's doing his best even
though he's yeah he can't provide a lot
of those things but he's providing love
he's trying to mow down the poor
yeah yeah that's the most important the
most important one the emotional
supports the most important aspect you
can have I want to be a dad now now I
want to be a dad so what we're talking
her before each other don't ya think dad
does does scare me cuz I want it I don't
want to want to be in like the pursuit
of happiness you know position where
your legs is constantly financially
struggling but if you can be that great
to the point where when you're around
your kid you don't take any of that [ __ ]
out on your kid yeah that would be
incredible I mean oh man have a lot of
no one's perfect but I've heard of many
parents who can definitely they do it
there are people that like exist like
that
speaking of fatherhood are there any
other any youtubers that you would
parent with I decided to make it out
anything i pair it with the parent you
that would be some science fiction yet
going on there but all right I'm cool we
can do it would be code ahead we kidnap
a kid we kidnap this little girl a
student was kidnapped this girl will be
the financial support you can be the
emotions yeah I'll be you cook a lot
brokers [ __ ] I'll be the neglectful
daddy's gotta film reactions right now
okay it's okay it's okay little stress
could be were the man that he puts us
video this is good you know used humor
to to get away from the tears for a
second
it's Truman there's you two guys in a
video were crying yeah I hope my drive
home today played on coming traffic
after that way what's his for Matt might
MetLife so in case something terrible
would happen to hot there the daughter
is covered okay oh my god this was hard
for me because you know my dad did pass
a few years ago and he learned he was
very much thank you
I don't know how to quite responded it
that's alright it's weird
here's a dollar lost a brother so I to
me lost a brother
we understand what this is died more to
our personal lives and everything but
it's hard because my dad did struggle he
was he was constantly financially
struggling and my mom was the primary
breadwinner this father portrayal kinda
reminded me like of a semi hybrid of
both of my parents no interesting if you
like it was a single father like there's
no mention of who the mom is in this
video but my parents were together well
of course and this in this universe the
mother passed away because why wouldn't
she
that's why she life insurance actually
provided a and my dad did struggle and
he wasn't like the best at concealing
the struggles the way how this dad was
what he did have the times to be able to
show love and nurturing and affection
those are the most valuable times to me
because when you grow up or you kind of
just used to being poor I wasn't the
kind of kid who was jealous of other
families or kids who did well yeah I
don't think I ever got jealous of that
idea I just kind of immediately accepted
in my situation but he has a situation
on Gate I see it in relationships I see
them families where the struggle to be
able to provide financially and
everything is so tough that you do take
it out on your loved ones so it is
important to be able to and I've had
that too in my past interactions ROM
like struggling and financially and then
I take that out I love the message of
this commercial that it really is about
the emotional support and the
transparency is okay and it's cool
letting the kids not like disappointed
in her dad she's like I still love you
despite whatever flaws you feel you have
oh and then there's so much closer at
the end yeah
um ah a rental embrace you gonna come
rich I'm gonna put myself in the same
exact scenario my kid so we could have
that bonding moment Harden's healthy
yeah the major manipulator especially
when he finds out the truth [ __ ]
filthy racial business [ __ ] [ __ ] my
dad is a liar yes so much money I'm
holding out on me
tears of joy you can subscribe to the
real rejects to Destin you can buy
MetLife colored shirt thank you to the
Filipino subscribers who requested this
Kylie Tyler man on Twitter and Instagram
he has the periscope videos you can
watch them right yeah these go to your
former periscope videos morning while I
was on there with John Humphrey
periscope TV slash the editor TV hasn't
mentioned that any of the other videos
the editor TV ok at there I'm extra me
link and go comm slash wine and while
--wow there's other things here and he's
work on YouTube channel called fan 30
keep a lookout good bye bye guys